لقد أدرت حملتك واعدت
بمؤيدين بأن المكسيك ستدفع
ثمن الحرب ، كل شيء سيكون مصنوعًا من
الخرسانة ،
كما قلت سابقًا أن الجدار
يمكن أن يكون مصنوعًا من الفولاذ ، والآن
تم إغلاق حكومتنا بناءً على طلب
من إدارتك بأن
دافع الضرائب الأمريكي يدفع ثمن الجدار ،
فكيف يمكنك أن تقول إنك لم تفشل في
الوفاء بهذا الوعد
لمؤيديك ، سؤال لطيف للغاية تم طرحه بشكل جميل على
الرغم من الإجابة عليه ، دعني فقط
أعذرني ، عفوا ، عفوا ، هل أنت
مستعد ، هل أنت  جاهز لقد أخبرتك
للتو أننا عقدنا صفقة تجارية
وسنتخذ مليارات ومليارات الدولارات
أكثر بكثير من تكلفة الجدار ،
الجدار هو الفول السوداني مقارنة
بقيمة هذه الصفقة التجارية بالنسبة
للولايات المتحدة.  كخرسانة ،
قلت إنني سأبني جدارًا ، لم أقل أبدًا أنني سأبني حائطًا ، قلت
إنني
سأبني جدارًا فقط حتى تعرف
ذلك لأنني أعلم أنك لست منخرطًا في
أعمال البناء التي لا
تفهمها  سميثي  نانوغرام لدينا الآن
أعمال فولاذية عظيمة أعيد بناؤها في
الولايات المتحدة. الصلب أقوى من
الخرسانة إذا قمت ببناء هذا الجدار أو السياج
أو أي شيء يحتاج الديمقراطيون إلى
تسميته لأنني لست من الأسماء التي
أعمل بها  شيء يعمل إذا قمت ببناء
جدار فولاذي بدلاً من جدار خرساني
، فسيكون في الواقع أقوى من
الفولاذ الخرساني أقوى من الخرسانة ،
في حالة يمكنك التحقق منه ، استمع إذا
قمت ببناء جدار وكان الجدار مصنوعًا
من الفولاذ بدلاً من ذلك  من الملموس أعتقد أن
الناس سيحبون ذلك ، وهنا
الشيء الجيد الآخر الذي سأفعله بواسطة
شركة الولايات المتحدة للصلب من قبل
الشركات في بلدنا التي أصبحت الآن
شركات كبيرة قوية مرة أخرى
وأصبحت قوية على مدار العامين الماضيين
بسببي  وبسبب سياساتنا التجارية ،
فإذا كان لديّ جدار فولاذي أو
يمكنك تسميته سياجًا فولاذيًا ،
لكنه سيكون أقوى من أي من
الجدران الخرسانية التي نتحدث عنها ،
فمن الممكن أن يبدو
أفضل  أحد الأشياء التي أعتقد أنك
رأيت هذا مهم جدًا بالنسبة لنا
للغاية في الحديث عن
جليد حرس الحدود وفي الواقع
تطبيق القانون المحلي وحتى العسكريين الذين يريدون
أن يكونوا قادرين على رؤيته من خلاله لا يمكنك
رؤيته حقًا من خلال  ملموس
جيدًا يريدون أن يكونوا قادرين على رؤية من
على الجانب الآخر من الجدار لأنه إذا
كانوا هنا ولديك حوالي 12
بوصة جدار خرساني ولديك أشخاص
على الجانب الآخر ولكن لا يمكنك رؤية
ما يوجد هناك  خطير جدا